So we've now seen that the algorithm that
we have, this branch
and bound algorithm, is not going to
perform well on noisy data sets.
And as soon as we go from 18 amino
acid masses
to 144, we're going to start to really
struggle with using this algorithm.
We're not going to give up on it, we just
need to
figure out if we can find more
information that's in that spectrum.
Is there something that the spectrum is
telling us that we just haven't
been listening to?
So our goal here is to say, we've got to
get the number of amino acid masses that
we consider down.
We've got to reduce these.
So, we've got to go from 144, wouldn't it
be nice
to knock that down to 50, or 20 or even
10,
in a great scenario?
Let's recall this spectrum that we had,
this hypothetical experimental spectrum.
And let's just see what we notice about
it.
This is a great
problem solving strategy, where
if you're stuck on a solution,
one of the most common things to do
is: consider a small example.
Look and see what that small example
is
telling you, and see if that maybe
generalizes.
So here's our small example.
It's just going to be for a peptide of
length four.
Then we're going to say, okay, well, we
can't detect
the mass of E, it's not in this
experimental spectrum,
so we're not going to identify that E is
one of our letters, one of our amino acids
that way.
But…hold on.
We do detect 257 which is the mass of QE.
And we do detect 128 which is the mass of
Q.
If you subtract these two masses, you
should get the mass of E.
E is what's left over with QE and Q.
So when you subtract
them, you get 129.
So that's good.
Can we find it anywhere else?
The answer is yes.
ELN is another subpeptide of this cyclic
peptide NQEL, as is LN.
And we notice that the masses of these two
are in the spectrum as well.
We get 356 minus 227 and that gives us
129.
We even get one more.
The mass of the entire peptide is 484.
And the mass of LNQ, the subpetide that
doesn't include E, is 355.
And when we subtract those we get 129.
So 129 is still there, right?
It may not be on the spectrum, but if we
start subtracting masses
that are in the spectrum, then we're
going to get three occurrences of 129.
This is going to motivate our definition
of what's called a “spectral convolution”.
So the convolution of a spectrum.
It's the positive difference between
every pair of masses in the spectrum.
So here is the same spectrum that we had,
we represent the masses along here,
and along here,
and we go through and we subtract every pair.
We have 227 here as the mass of LN.
We don't know it's the mass of LN, but we
have 227.
And here we have the mass detected of 370
and when we subtract
them, we get 143.
And we can do this for every pair and we
form this table.
Now, I've highlighted certain masses, and
I'll tell you why I've done that.
The reason is, we want to ask, what are
the most frequent elements between 57 and
200?
Because remember with E, we picked it up
in a
number of different places, we picked it
up three different times.
So we want to ask ourselves, what are the
most frequent elements between 57 and 200,
and there's
a good chance that's going to give us what the
amino acids should be.
The five most frequent elements that I
highlighted
are: 99, 113 114, 128 and 129, and when
we convert those from the integer mass
table, we see that that's V, L, N, Q, and E.
They correspond to those letters.
If we take the five most frequent
elements,
four of them are going to give us the amino acids
of NQEL.
This is really promising on this small example.
So now we have the
outline of an algorithm called
ConvolutionCyclopeptideSequencing,
and the first thing that it's going to do
is to say
OK, given our experimental spectrum,
let's form the spectral convolution of it.
Then we're going to look at that spectral
convolution and
say, “what are the most frequent elements
in it”?
We may choose this parameter,
capital M,
taking the M most frequent elements
between 57 and 200,
so M may be 50 or 20 in practice.
And then we're going to run our
leaderboard algorithm using only those
top M masses that we found between 57 and 200
in the spectral convolution,
and we're going to form our peptides only
on those integer masses.
The question then is,
does this algorithm really work?
That's the question that we constantly
ask, right?
And so let's consider Spectrum10.
Remember, when we expanded our alphabet,
the leaderboard method didn't work for
Spectrum10.
So, let's see if it works for Spectrum10
now that we're dealing with the
convolution.
So the first step is,
take the convolution.
Then we pick the ten most frequent
elements in
that convolution, which I'm showing here
on the right.
Most of these are actually standard masses
or correspond to standard amino acids.
So 145 was nonstandard but the other ones
were identified as standard.
Then we run the algorithm on only these
amino acids,so these are the only amino
acids that
will be allowed in our peptide, and the
winning peptide
is Tyrocidine B1 and we should be
happy.
So it reconstructed the correct peptide
just
from taking the ten most frequent elements
in the spectral convolution, so it worked
really, really well.
Well then we ask ourselves, OK, what
about Spectrum25?
What about this noisier spectrum that
none of our
algorithms has been able to correctly
reconstruct Tyrocidine B1 from?
What happens if we apply
ConvolutionCyclopeptideSequencing
to that really noisy spectrum?
And when we do it, it's good news.
We can reconstruct Tyrocidine B1 again and
so now we can start the party.
But I do want to mention one more thing
about practical considerations, and I'll do that
in the next section.